the Glazer why is now the right time to  sell Manchester United hi well as we  announced yesterday the board went  through a process and it's decided it's  going to look at different strategic  Alternatives and that's what we're doing  so United fans say that you should have  sold the club years ago  well once again we've gone through a  process we're going to look at all  different all strategic Alternatives and  we'll see where that leads us so I  appreciate you talking to me tonight and  I'm going to wish everyone a Happy  Thanksgiving Cristiano Ronaldo says that  you don't care about the club and  thousands of United fans agree with him  why why should they be wrong well I'll  tell you about Cristiano Ronaldo he's a  great Management Center player I  appreciate everything he's done for the  club and I wish him the best luck in the  future thanks very much why did he have  to leave the club why did he have to  leave the club